[Music]
so in today's video we are going to talk
about what is DevOps via DevOps is
needed and why it is gaining so much
popularity in recent times then you will
try and understand where does clout fit
in here and then finally we will take a
look at Microsoft Azure stack for DevOps
which is also known as visual studio
team services so let's first try and
understand what exactly DevOps is as for
the definition given on the internet it
is a combination of cultural
philosophies practices and tools that
increases an organization's ability to
deliver applications and services at
high velocity now high velocity is the
key word here if you remember a couple
of months back or maybe couple of years
back it was quite normal to deliver an
application in three months time or six
months time a typical deployment
frequency was at least of water but
today if you talk about the top
performing companies companies who are
right at the top their frequency is a
couple of times deployments every single
day right so they're doing multiple
deployments in a single day in 24 hours
time on their production machines that
is how fast they have become so it's
really important to implement the bops
practices in order to do that without
divorce that would not be possible at
all you cannot even think about multiple
deployments in a single T if you don't
have DevOps practices implemented in
your company so essentially you try to
get this pipeline wherein you have a
bell build test and release pipeline and
which actually then you monitor your
customers their behavior and then plan
accordingly for the next set of
enhancements and bug fixes and things
like that so this is a continuous
process it goes on and on and on so now
we understand what exactly divorce is
all about then let's try and understand
why it has become so popular in recent
times with the IT companies the first
and foremost important benefit of DevOps
is that it makes your developers and
operations folks to collaborate in a
much fairer way
with a lot less friction they have a
common goal and what they want to do is
essentially to make sure that the
application is up and running which is
the primary task and what happens is
they collaborate in a much better way
they understand each other's problems
and they understand each other's way of
working and which actually helps
productivity increment for both of them
the most practices such as continuous
integration continuous delivery
infrastructure as code etc they make it
possible to release the code or very
faster than before with almost no errors
which results in faster time-to-market
and minimized failed deployments now a
faster time to market or time to market
is a concept of an idea which has been
first thought about and then you know it
went through the process of designing
and implementing and coding and then
finally testing and finally you have an
end result which goes to the end users
so that process the whole time taken is
known as time to market which becomes
increasingly faster if you are
implementing DevOps in your projects now
because of all these combination of
practices and cultural changes and all
those things you have a shared
responsibility model which actually
helps in increased collaboration as we
have seen before and faster releases so
these two what happens in turn increases
overall productivity of every individual
and the team and overall you become much
more productive what then what we have
been in the past
now puppet labs and adora which is a
DevOps research organization they
publish every year one report which is
known as state of DevOps report which
they compile after doing a lot of
surveys of the IT individuals and the
companies they have been publishing the
support for the past five six years now
already and if you go and take a look at
all these past reports which are
available on the internet free of cost
you don't have to pay anything for it
you can just type in state of their
support and they ear for which you want
it and you can get the report in a PDF
format this report basically compiles a
lot of information about the people who
are trying to implement on who have
implemented it devolves in the past
and what are the benefits they have been
able to see after implementing DevOps
and some of the most important benefits
are first of all it is frequent
deployments as we have seen before the
rate of deployment becomes very fast and
it get reduce from months to quarters
from one strand quarters to becomes
weeks and days and hours you can
actually do do deployments in an hourly
fashion instead of in a monthly or
quarterly fashion then we have a faster
MTTR MP l stands for mean time to
recovery so let's say if there is a
failed deployment how long it takes for
you to make your application normal up
and running again so that whole time is
typically calculated in the form of MP
PR and that's actually if you see on the
screen it is 24 times faster than
previous or 24 times faster than an on
the box products project compared to a
DevOps project then of course we have a
very less number of failed deployments
if you are on a DevOps framework and
finally we have a very shorter lead
times now lead times actually indicates
the time given to the deployment a team
to get ready for the deployments so
let's say you told your deployment team
that today you are telling that you the
the deployment has to be done two days
afterwards so that gives you basically
48 hours to the deployment teams right
so that gets reduced to from weeks two
days and then from these two hours as
per gene Kim who is one of the major
chief evangelists for DevOps one of the
way how you measure DevOps you know
implementation is if you say your
deployment team that you have to deploy
a software right now and if their answer
is anything but yes that would mean that
they still need to work on their
demonstrate work so if you are
completely on DevOps you should be able
to deploy anytime and anywhere
so now we have understood what is DevOps
and why divorce has become so popular
now let's try and understand the
relationship between DevOps and
which are two of the most happening
technologies at the moment so the first
and the most important relationship is
that they are complementary to each
other what happens is there are lot of
principles and a lot of you know
technologies which are common to DevOps
and cloud and what happens is if you
implement DevOps you are helping your
cloud infrastructure and if you have a
cloud infrastructure it actually helps
you to get on a DevOps framework much
quicker what happens is a combination of
DevOps and cloud provides you a definite
advantage over your competition and
cloud actually makes it easy to
implement in Tawaf services because of
inherent abstraction of complexities so
what happens is you don't need to bother
about whether your tools are going to be
integrated or not whether you have to
have written the glue code or not things
like that you have all the framework
already in front of you and you just
need to get up and rolling with your
develops implementation if you are
working in cloud whereas if you are
working on some on-premise solution
let's say you have a traditional data
center in which you are trying to
implement a box it will always be more
complex then on if you're doing the same
thing on the cloud and finally cloud as
you're aware it gives you this added
advantage of agility scalability and
on-demand
availability these are some of the
things which are inherent to cloud the
moment you talk about cloud the moment
you implement cloud all these things
come naturally to these other things
which are which you get by default if
you are on cloud so so these things
actually help in your DevOps
implementation so Microsoft has given
their DevOps services a name which is
known as a visual studio team services
and all the devops related services have
been compiled over here so let's take a
look at what exactly those are and how
they have been divided and what are
actually what do they offer you so as
the name as you can see is visual studio
team services and whatever if you want
to you know make a full fledge at a
DevOps pipeline starting from plan to
code to build to test and release you
are supposed to work with visual studio
team services
and you can actually it is very fast and
easy for you to plan build and ship
software across a variety of platforms
you can actually get up and running in
minutes on Azure it's out without having
to install or configure a single server
you can access your projects your code
and work items through an integrated
experience or within Visual Studio or
you can use free plugins which are
already available for you and for
example you have support for git client
you have support for Xcode you have
modern web browser interface and you can
use your favorite development tool to
tailor visual studio team services to
your team's
needs and you get you know free private
code repositories you can track your
bugs work items feedback you have in
build edge I plan to live here on agile
a framework you get all the tools in
built with visual studio team services
you have continuous integration builds
which are already inbuilt into the
platform you can develop and work in any
language all the major languages such as
dotnet and Java and Python and Ruby all
of them are supported by visual studio
team services you get this
infrastructure as code ability with the
help of issue a resource manager which
is you can think of it as a counterpart
for share for puppet and for monitoring
we have something called application
insights which is the inbuilt
monitoring tool which is provided to you
within visual studio team services so
let's take a look at one by one some of
these some of the most important
services which are which are given by
which Willis studio or team services or
also known as Microsoft Azure team
services and the first one in the list
is of course source code management now
in Microsoft Azure you have actually two
options if you want to use distributed
version control system you have an
option of gate and if you are a big fan
of centralized version control systems
then you have this option of TFS team
foundation version control as you are
aware of it already
and visual studio team services actually
lets you connect directly to any git
repository
service provider including the get or
let's say TFS or maybe github bitbucket
your private repository or even
subversion you can automatically trigger
your pipeline from changes to your code
and authentication part is taken care by
typically get credential manager or SSH
so visual studio team services lets you
perform most common gate tasks you will
need for your day-to-day work right from
Visual Studio and you have team Explorer
and you have git command line which work
great together and when you make updates
and perform commands through one
interface you'll be able to see those
changes reflected in the editor you can
limit who can contribute to specific
branches and automatically include the
right reviewers for every code change so
you get all the capabilities which you
would like to have in your source code
management suite so next in line we have
continuous integration and legal studio
team services lets you integrate with
any of the application stack of your
choice force tests for testing and
integration in order to achieve
continuous integration now
high-performing teams practice container
integration and continuous delivery
now we shall history team services not
only automates the build and testing and
deployment of your app which actually
gives you complete traceability to see
everything in the bill including changes
to your code reviews and test results it
actually lets you integrate with any
application stack of your choice as we
have seen before and you can actually
work on all major platforms such as
Windows Linux and iOS and with Suites
like maven any unit j-unit etc when you
talk about continuous delivery or build
and release related services again you
have a host of services at your disposal
and actually you know visual studio team
services and team foundation server
which actually helps you implement a
highly customizable content integration
and deployment pipeline and as we have
seen before you can use any of the
application stack for your purpose you
can develop your code in dotnet in Java
in nodejs PHP Python anything anything
of your choice right and similarly you
have multiple ways to deploy it in
multiple locations you can deploy your
application visual studio team services
actually supports deploying your
application to virtual machines to
containers if you have a nice data
center or if you have any of the cloud
platforms or pass services you can
deploy anywhere you like
if your goal is to produce packages
which can be consumed by others so even
that has been given as a capability in
visual studio team services you have a
built-in package management repository
and now you can package and publish your
application bits as let's say you get
NPM or maven packages into the built-in
repository or into any other package
management repository of your choice now
when it comes to monitoring we have
application insights now application in
psychics is an extensible application
performance management service for web
developers who are building and managing
apps on multiple platforms with
application insights you can actually
quickly find out how your app is
performing and being used when it is
life let's say if there is a problem it
lets you know about it you can help it
actually helps you assess the impact and
helps you determine the cost it actually
lets you increase your visibility over
application and brings your operation
and application data together in one
place so you have all the capabilities
of a modern continuous monitoring
application within the form of
application insights which is a inbuilt
application in Azure stack so when we
talk about infrastructure as code we
again have inbuilt tool within your zero
stack which is known as Azure a resource
manager and when we talk about
infrastructure when you think about your
application infrastructure you think of
many components right you think of
virtual machine you think of storage
account you think of network components
of web app database you know third-party
services you don't you don't see these
components as separate entities right so
you see them as related and
interdependent parts of a single entity
you want to deploy manage and monitor
them as a group and that's what is
you're a resource manager lets you do it
you can actually deploy update or delete
all the resources for your solution in a
single coordinated operation you use a
template for deployment and that
template can work for different
environments such as testing staging and
production resource manager provides
security auditing tracking features to
help you manage your resources even
after deployments now agile tools
actually they help you you know you can
track everything in a single place with
the help of agile tools and they kind of
give you all the management related
capabilities when you want to have you
know a bird's-eye view of your overall
DevOps infrastructure so you have this
dashboard availability in which you can
actually see in a nutshell at a glance
you can take a look at what exactly is
going on with your infrastructure now
let's say you are working on a if you're
working on a scrum or Kanban you know if
you're working on that model and let's
say you have a Kanban boards at your
disposal and you have even a scrum
boards at your disposal you can actually
capture new features and bugs or any
other work item into your backlogs you
can actually customize your task boards
as per your needs you know so that you
can track your team progress or you can
use a child portfolio management for
larger groups to track work across all
of the teams now apart from all these
whatever we have discussed so far we
have something called a Visual Studio
marketplace now this is a place it is an
online store that offers applications
and services either built in or designed
to integrate with I should a cloud
platform now let's say we have discussed
all the tools beforehand right we have
been discussing for the last five
minutes or so but let's say you need a
tool which is not there in the list so
you need to come to the marketplace and
this will give you whatever tools you
need for your DevOps pipeline you will
have those tools available here are the
products and service
which are sold through the Israeli
market place actually they come either
from Microsoft directly or the the
technology partners so with market place
actually you can integrate as your a
cloud with a host of technologies like
as you can see on the screen you have
Jenkins talker red gate we have
elasticsearch MongoDB Cassandra you know
NetScaler fi big IP and and and a lot
more actually now as you know
marketplace also supports various
pricing models let's say bring your own
license model or pay-as-you-go model or
even free software extensions so all
these extensions are available on
marketplace and they are certified by
Microsoft to ensure compatibility with
the usherette cloud platform and as of
mid 2016 as you remarket place has more
than 3500 products organized into
several categories so in order to
summarize whatever we have discussed if
you if you see today's IT world but most
of the companies they are actually today
adopting both cloud and divorce it's
actually even more important to
understand both the technologies in
right perspective and you know how they
can complement each other now cloud
makes it much easier and productive to
adopt their works practices and on the
other hand DevOps makes the ROI on cloud
adoption even more lucrative for any
company dealing with software delivery
and as we have seen Microsoft Azure a
gives you a host of support
you know services and technologies to
work with and make your life smooth as a
DevOps Egeria so I hope that you found
that information
good for your knowledge and thank you
for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here